wir haben es gesagt am anfang der
sendung ist stellen sich jetzt mehrere
große fragen die weit darüber
hinausgehen ob man mal kurz über
whatsapp nicht erreichbar war die eine
große frage ist ist es zu gefährlich
wenn sie so viel macht in kommunikations
macht in der hand eines konzerns liegt
also das ist glaube ich eine frage die
man ganz klar mit ja beantworten kann
und wir haben es jetzt gestern über
sechs stunden deutlich erlebt dass ein
konzern oder wie wichtig ein konzern wie
facebook nicht nur für die private
kommunikation sondern auch für die
firmenkommunikation ist mittlerweile in
deutschland beispielsweise nutzt jedes
zweite unternehmen
soziale netzwerke wie facebook wie
whatsapp auch wie twitter das gehört nun
nicht zu facebook und daran erkennen wie
wichtig es ist auch als verbraucher oder
als firma nicht nur auf einen konzern zu
setzen sondern immer noch
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten
beispielsweise über twitter zu haben
also mindestens zwei
kommunikationswege zu nutzen von zwei
unterschiedlichen firmen womöglich sogar
mal das telefon seien ganz klar das
telefon also der der wirtschaftliche
schaden das ist ja auch eine
entscheidende größe über die wir
sprechen müssen die könnte bei facebook
was diese sechs stunden angeht bei
ungefähr 90 millionen euro liegen das
schätzen analysten aber der schaden denn
deren der dann über facebook hinaus geht
der ist natürlich viel viel höher der
geht weltweit mutmaßlich in die
milliarden weil einfach so viele firmen
dran hängen weil einfach so viele firmen
ihre kommunikation auch über whatsapp
beispielsweise steuern oder über
instagram das sind die dinge die müssen
heute sicherlich auf den tisch da wird
man genauere zahlen im laufe des tages
haben aber ich lege mich schon mal fest
das geht in die milliarden und haben
auch in asien insbesondere tschuldigung
sei aber insbesondere auch in asien aber
noch viel mehr als hier viele firmen
komplett über facebook sind komplett
abhängig davon und übrigens eine
interessante erkenntnis die nebenbei
jetzt auch herauskam war wie viel geld
facebook mit werbung verdient ist
nämlich eine halbe million euro in der
stunde richtig genau und zwar nur den
usa das muss man auch mal sagen es gibt
natürlich den asiatischen markt den
europäischen markt also da kommen einige
millionen allein in einer stunde
zusammen wie gesagt ungefähr sagt man
der umsatz von facebook an einem tag
liegt so bei etwas über 300 millionen
euro wenn dann da sechs stunden lang gar
nichts passiert dann sind wir ungefähr
bei 80 millionen je nachdem also wir
sehen dass facebook kennen da extrem
wichtig ist eine extrem wichtige
marktmacht hat interessant auch wie die
börsen beispielsweise heute morgen jetzt
reagiert nachdem es gestern rund fünf
prozent runter gegen mark zuckerberg
rund sechs milliarden euro leichter
innerhalb von sechs stunden heute geht
es wieder rauf 2 prozent im plus das
heißt mark zuckerberg hat diese sechs
milliarden schon auf drei milliarden
verlust reduzieren können wer weiß wo er
ende des tages dann steht vielleicht ist
es auch wieder viele und mark zuckerberg
auch nicht mehr der drittreichste mann
der welt sondern jetzt auf platz fünf er
arbeitet sich hinter heute
wahrscheinlich wonach eltern und ich
habe davon dass jetzt der ton zu martin
eisenlauer steht unser it experte bei
bild ja und das alles nur martin wegen
eines motorproblems dass sich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen klein anhört
aber eine riesige dimension hatte wie
kann das sein ja es zeigt vor allen
dingen ein großes problem dass facebook
offensichtlich hatte es gab ja eine
erklärung eines ingenieurs der jetzt
gesagt hat ja wir hatten da ein
konfigurations problem des routers und
das war alles gar nicht so schlimm steht
da drin die wahrheit ist aber die
tatsache dass so ein update gemacht
werden kann ohne dass das überprüft wird
und ohne dass es sofort seine vorbeck
lösung gibt also eine notlösung wenn
eben dieses problem auftritt zeigt wie
wenig man sich da wirklich um
datensicherheit bei diesem unternehmen
bemüht und wie riskant da gespielt wird
und warum dauert das dann sechs sieben
stunden ist es wieder funktioniert ja
das bekannte ärgernis an der geschichte
war offensichtlich dass die menschen die
das hätten ändern können nicht dort
waren wo die server standen und man sie
quasi auch online nicht mehr erreicht
hatte also auch facebook selbst litt
darunter dass aldi facebook dienste
nicht mehr gingen wir haben gestern
nacht noch mit einem experten gesprochen
er sagt die konfiguration die sich da
zeigt das wäre ein absoluter anfänger
fehler dass man eben alles über diesen
diesen bereich facebook.com laufen lässt
und wenn er dann weg ist es eben
wirklich alles weg eben auch der zugriff
zu den servern mal denn wir kennen das
ja alle von zu hause manchmal router
probleme gibt dann zieht man den stecker
raus ganz rudimentär und wartet eine
minute und steckt ihn wieder rein wie
muss man sich das bei so einem riesigen
unternehmen vorstellen dass die ganze
welt bedient ja es ist tatsächlich
einerseits ein bisschen so also die
mussten gestern auch tatsächlich zu den
servern hin sind zurücksetzen der alte
software wieder aufspielen die
funktioniert hat auf der anderen seite
ist es aber eben auch nicht ganz so
einfach wir haben gestern gesehen als
facebook dann wieder da war dass es noch
sehr sehr lange dauerte bis die gesamten
systeme wieder wie gewohnt funktioniert
haben und das liegt schlicht daran dass
diese server weltweit natürlich verteilt
sind so dass man sie immer schnell
erreichen kann und auch der anderen
seite dann aber eben auch ein bisschen
länger brauchen wenn sie mal nicht
funktionieren und dann läuft das quasi
so im notbetrieb ne zeit lang und muss
sich dann erst wieder zurecht ruckeln
das sehen wir heute morgen sind wir
wieder da wo wir sonst auch gewohnt mit
facebook umgehen können gestern abend
war das teilweise wirklich noch konnte
man zusehen wie die seiten sich aufbauen
vielen dank martin eisenlauer unser it
experte von bild ich habe wer den
schaden hat muss für den spott nicht
groß sorgen der aufschrei dieses mega
groß war natürlich in den sozialen
netzwerken riesig und während instagram
facebook und what's up down waren ist
twitter explodiert natürlich tv comedian
jan böhmermann beispielsweise schrieb
das hier wir blenden es mal ein
hoffentlich gehen whats app instagram
und facebook nie wieder an den start
geht es nie wieder an schrieb er es gab
jede menge andere down at the same time
das ist hier ein gutes beispiel dafür
wie was wo von der abhängig sind hieß es
da wie teilen wir die leute von facebook
auf twitter und telegramm sind heute wie
biontech und moderner also die
konkurrenz unternehmen das erste mal
seit 2010 über sms kommuniziert in der
tat ich habe auch eine sms von meiner
tochter bekommen und war sehr verwundert
darüber ein eine sprachaufnahme über sms
bekommen ja ist ganz schäfer bei uns im
studio noch wir haben darüber gesprochen
es gibt eine anhörung heute im us
kongress eine whistleblowing die
ausgepackt hat wie
facebook und co ihre macht missbrauchen
offensichtlich in dem versuch so
schreibt es zumindest die new york times
heute in dem versuch neue kundschaft zu
gewinnen denn manche mutmaßen die beste
zeit von facebook im kurs vorbei mit
blick auf den aktienkurs kann man das
zumindest nicht sagen die aktie von
facebook reagiert neue allzeithoch auch
trotz des absturzes gestern und deswegen
hat mark zuckerberg versucht sich
insgesamt zu verbreitern nicht nur
facebook sondern auch andere plattformen
wie instagram dazu zu kaufen aber faktum
und richtig ist heute gibt es diese
anhörung vor dem us-senat eine ehemalige
produktmanagerin frances hogan packt aus
und macht extrem schwere vorwürfe also
sie sagt unter anderem das facebook eine
plattform sei wo sich das drogenkartell
in mexiko beispielsweise austausche wo
auch menschenhändler in asien
aufträge rekrutieren facebook so ist der
vorwurf sei das alles bekannt reagiere
aber nicht darauf sondern lasse das zu
also sei mittendrin und tief verstrickt
in diese ganzen kriminellen und schwer
kriminellen machenschaften so die
aussagen von frances hogan und das ist
etwas was heute vor dem us senat kommt
und das ist sicherlich was wir auch
gestern erwähnt haben das viel größere
problem was mark zuckerberg jetzt in den
nächsten wochen und monaten dann
wahrscheinlich zu lösen hat dann kannst
du was darüber sagen ob ich die
möglichkeit habe
schadensersatzforderungen zu stellen
wenn ich mein geschäft darüber betreibe
und siebenstündigen ausfall hatte da
kenne ich die geschäftsbedingungen
ehrlich gesagt nicht einzelner firmen
das muss man dann glaube ich von vertrag
zu vertrag klären und dann gibt es ja
auch immer dieses thema höhere gewalt
bis so ein wenn es dann so ein router
wechsel angeblich gewesen so solche
probleme ist dass höhere gewalt kann man
das einschätzen als kunde würde ich auf
jeden fall erstmal versuchen
schadensersatzansprüche geltend zu
machen ein auch an facebook an die
entsprechende rechtsabteilung schreiben
und auch die ausfälle beziffern das
macht immer sinn und dann geht es am
ende vielleicht dann vor ein gericht und
dann entscheiden richter aber versuchen
würde ich auf jeden fall
[Musik]